jedes wahrscheinlich genauso wenig wie
ich mit diesem video hier gerechnet ich
mache seit längerer zeit mal wieder
gaming zusammen mit lucas sebastian und
wir spielen skript mio
das ist ein sehr tolles spiel wo man
sachen zeichnen muss ich hab youtuber
als kassel words eingegeben das heißt
wir müssen probieren youtuber zu
zeichnen haye wäre es eigentlich heute
dabei motivation ist da los
ich war direkt nach der wahl nicht wir
und warum hat der brüste ich hab' ich
habe das nächste wort ich werde erst mal
zeichnen
aber was gerade die echte postleitzahl
von hallo sebastian ich nehme
okay das kann ich dachte er wäre im
boden muss anders machen wie kannst du
bis 110 die polizei
[Musik]
ihr müsst unbedingt lukas video schauen
das ist auch jetzt gerade online
gegangen auch die ganze zeit irgendwas
geschrieben weil direkt wir schicken
würde 321 o mein gott was davon haben
wenn ich schnell zu groß guck mal was
der baut da oben
junge fall schreibt man eben die
höchsten standards geben mit ds richtig
geschrieben
sie fanden ein lamborghini
die haben alle zu kurzen armen jungen
das wird so schnell gehen halter okay
ich hab mich haben lukas klingeln gehört
und dachte ich hätte es richtig aber ich
habe sie geschrieben
wieder gab antreten
bei bereit wenn ich keinen song bvvg das
ist der typ da schon immer so und da
immer dass die jungs denkt doch mal nach
das hier ja ich darf ja nicht sagen aber
ich war nie ist der juristischen tor
leute denkt mal nach geht nicht wir
kennen wir kennen ja ok ja damit ist
erwarten könnt macht keinen sinn dann
schon erwartet okay das war schlecht ist
16,3 waffe der staat müsse das motto war
das eine waffel junge das sieht aus wie
ein goldenes aus der waffe eines stücks
ist die perfekte waffe okay
[Gelächter]
ja das andere das anders ich habe leider
keinen dem wir zeichnen wir werden schon
hatten
das war ein bisschen schnell gemalt
[Gelächter]
ja ja der fährt auch drahtesel auto
hinweg schreibt mal im roten kreis mag
man roten möglicher unten auf andere
länder in afrika natur nicht so schnell
wachsen wie so weiter als wir gewinnen
sind wir schnell bei den schwachen
[Gelächter]
vielleicht wird es bei max anders
dargestellt
also jetzt gezeigt wie gemein führung
jungs führung nicht vertippt
hast du dich fragst du dich fertig marx
karl tv hast du dich fertig
was ist ein vertipper junger mann
stewart schreiben
[Gelächter]
hey leute wir haben neun wir haben 99
youtube 130 mehr bekommen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die sache ist nur ich weiß wie
unsympathisch geschrieben wird
auf der heute nur an den augen erkannt
diese scheiße und dabei den vielen
geschrieben
ich habe auch schon drei mal irgendwie
zuschauer bekommen aber nie genommen
okay leute die jetzt wirklich unserem
fahrzeug sehen wir mal was neues jahr
ich würde sagen ein video das
seinesgleichen sucht es war sehr lustig
sehr unkoordiniert und das hier noch mal
seht ich habe nicht nur die fünf leute
rein geschrieben die die ganze zeit
daran kam zwar noch ein paar mehr drin
so zum beispiel ist es besser hatten wir
nie also leute ist auf jeden fall ich
mein verschulden dass die spd sehr
positiv geworden ist sondern lediglich
das fressen